hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
our coverage with the match max in
Russia lagravis Alireza fallujah so
basically the unofficial French
championship as of course Maxime is
French and fallujah has been living in
France for quite some time now and when
he's finally finished switching
federations it is I believe he will play
for for the French Federation so
basically two of the strongest French
players here and Maxime with the white
piece so this is a game three and the
first two games ended in a draw and
let's see what happens here Maxime with
the white pieces opens with d4 we ignite
to have six c4 e6 Knight to c3 and now
Bishop to b4 valleys are going for the
nimzo-indian defense probably probably
the the best defense there is I mean I
enjoyed the most it doesn't mean it's
actually best it's just that I enjoyed
the most against d4 so Queen to c2
Maxime goes for the classical line and a
lot of commentators were saying that
this is maybe not the correct approach
against such a strong player like
holidays --i as it's well to basically
over analysed and it's hard for white to
push for anything here but okay future
goes for c5 immediately strikes in the
center we have d captures on c5 and now
you could go for night to a6 to grabbed
upon this way you can continue Bishop
captures but first if you lose your
castles to safety we have a three now
forcing black the capture Bishop
captures on c5 and now Knight to f3
now magazine continues developing and
here we have D 5 b6 is the most often
played move here but fiducia prepared
something else we have d5 Bishop to g5
by Maxine now pressuring this night and
now Bishop back to e 7 so the knight can
now move and there are a few games in
the database for e3 and series seek
after sandy if I were played but here
rook to d1 and it is as of mu9 that we
have a completely new game so you should
definitely move your queen away from the
D file which is what
Fallujah does with Queen to a5 as the
knight is pinned and III maxime wants to
finish development and castle
is King to safety with h6 now asking do
you want to go back or do you want to
trade here and here maxime trades and
it's a again a general principle and
that you do not trade unless you
actually gain something from that trade
you know it's the good old to take is a
mistake so what does Maxine gain here so
this is what he finds Bishop captures
Bishop captures C captures on d5 he
captures and now you cannot go for the
pawn right away because if you capture
it black will just eliminate one of the
defenders with check and after you
recapture you just lose the rook yeah
that's all there is to it so after 85
Maxine found the b4 this is a his idea
behind the capture now trying to offer
the a three point for the for the d5
pawn but max fallujah decides to keep
the pawn so Queen here now putting
pressure on the night here and again you
cannot move it as the Queen we just hang
so look the c1 and now Queen back to d8
again keeping an eye on his d5 pawn
Queen to d2 again attacking it and now
Bishop to e6 future just defended so
after all this is said and done our
future keeps his pawn and it's an it's
an isolated deep on so we'll see if it
will be a weakness or or a strength in
the position so Bishop e2 finally Maxine
is ready to finish development and
Knight to c6 now we have castles by
Maxine and now as the future does have
this expanded structure on the Queen
side Maxime attacks that with a 5 so b5
just advancing the pawn grabbing more
space on the Queen side Knight to e7 and
now not a 4 just yet but first a knight
the a4 he wants to shift his knight over
to c5 we have Queen to b6 and now nice
to see 5 as planned and here going for
b6 wouldn't be all that impressive as
now nice the e4 could put put black into
some difficulties as okay you do grab
the a3 point but white shatters your
king side and Indian do you even have
Queen D Queen before going for the d f6
ended the beasts exponents so not really
not really much for black so instead
fallujah goes rook F the c8 now with a
double attack on the night and
a trap for Maxine now if Maxine goes for
night capture Sun be 7 then Queen b6
just traps the night and but it's not
it's not at all clear right away because
let's say you trade once captures
captures and now you capture the pawn on
e5 seems like your knight escapes but
Bishop the c3 is still just captures the
knight after the Queen moves of course
so after this rook have to see it
magazine captures on e6
we have F captures on e6 now the d5 pawn
is no longer isolated and E for now as
ferocious Queen on d6 is undefended
we have Knight to g6 and now he captures
on d5 and now not recapturing right away
but first Knight to f4 again fallujah
sets a trap for Maxime for example if
you go for for one more pawn grab then
it's rook captures on c1 and after you
recapture now just captures captures and
of course captures with check picking up
the rook and c1 so after Knight to a4
with Bishop to c4 by Maxine
and now just keeping an eye on
everything here and Knight captures on
d5 winning back the pawn and only now a
for strengthening this structure here
and as the King occupies the same
diagonal as the bishop first King to a
trade by future and now g3 Maxine also
takes a moment to create some breathing
room for his King Queen to b4
few Janna offers a queen trade which
would give him a passed pawn if 88%
before a curse but first Maxine goes for
Bishop captures and d5 Queen captures on
b2 now Knight character sandy 2 nd
captures on d5 and here we have this
position that the material is equal and
it's a night against the bishop and here
you probably go rook FD one rook fe1
or something in those lines and continue
playing the game however Maxime play
tonight the b3 and this allowed fuchsia
are a very interesting idea
rook the c4 and now threatening of
course the capture da for pawn but also
if just row characters and c4 then you
get another pass pawn and with the
bishop slicing all the way here it would
be an incredibly strong pass pawn so
here rook F the d1 Maxime wants the
trade pawn for pawn and fuchsia goes for
it rook captures an a4
but now not capturing and D
right away - as this is followed by rook
the b4 going well
by putting pressure on the pawn and also
attacking the knight and after the
knight moves now you start pushing the
the past pawn so it would be also very
strong so instead after rook captures on
a4 we have Knight the c5 now putting
pressure on the rook but still rook the
b4 and here Knight captures on b7
instead here now maxime also creates a
passed pawn but fiducia doesn't even
bother with recapturing on b5 he just
starts pushing the phone so upon to a
fourth we have rook to c2 preparing to
block the pawn on analytes where of
course with a three and now rook the a2
however this doesn't work so i feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for Fallujah while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the the
correct winning idea and for those who
just want to enjoy the show the quickest
way to win is a rook to be - you could
start with rush of the ascent another
defender here but rook to be - is the
most straightforward one and this is
what fallujah chooses and now it's not
not easy to defend for example if you
capture capture there is no defense
against roque one that's that just ends
the game whatever you play King here you
still go route k1 and you either trade
or black gets a queen into the game on
the other hand if you try something like
rook to a1 then it's a bit trickier but
still still very interesting Bishop to
e7 you kind of kind of guard the pawn
and then you allow this rook captures
pawn captures you kind of blunder rook
but then after the King moves as the
king is in check there's no way to stop
promotion so that's another problem for
a for maxime so instead maxim plate
looked the d2 but here if you just
played rook captures and e2 and it was
in this position unmoved 35 that maxime
beaugeois graphic design/credits
if the rook is captured a - and with
this will this will be followed by a 1 a
promotion and of course that's a game so
yeah that's a game 3 of their match and
game 4
I will have set ended in a draw it was
any it was a really really
long game and the Maxine was really
pressuring he had he was up a piece but
he was unable to unable to get more than
a draw as Fallujah defended properly and
that just did so Game one two and four
ended in a draw a future wins Game three
and with this game three he also wins
the match so this will definitely impact
the standings but we're going to check
out the standings after the the round
completes as both Magnus and Maxine lost
their game so now it's probably Hikaru
who who will really fight today to grab
full three points and and take the lead
but yeah yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Terrance Nolan yawn or ask him
Steve Wacha Thomas Connors and Roland
Miller for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I think you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day